work that Runway let me see you working
Runway girl work that Runway Serena
Williams's daughter Olympia knows how to
serve more specifically down a Runway I
love her so much and you know we have a
great little family going on the
four-year-old's Shining Moment started
during some mother-daughter time as the
two explored Serena's children's book
The Adventures of quay quay oh girl
we're gonna do your hair today I was
thinking we could do it like in the book
of Avengers of Quake what do you think
you like her hair I do too that's why
that's not true yes it is it's not tell
me about your day wait at the salon girl
I want to hear all about your day after
some time at the salon the pair then
read lines from the book get it baby
girl a quick way shouts work that Runway
let me see you work the runway in
Olympia she does just that
ankles work that Runway girl work that
Runway I'm never a day without Olympia
like she's my priority and every day I
like need to be home with her because I
don't I don't want to miss any moments
with her the sweet moment comes nearly a
month after Olympia supported her mama
at the U.S open apparently she was
saying like Go Mama I'm so proud of you
and I was like what Serena won that
match but ultimately lost in the third
round marking what is likely the final
match in her career earlier this month
the tennis icon revealed in a Vogue
essay she's evolving away from the sport
she's created everything she does she's
still the best player to play right now
she could be number one if she so
desired so it's incredible to see the
way she walked away from the game still
the best Venus may just be Serena's
biggest fan but Olympia she's giving
Venus a run for her money after I had I
lost in Cincinnati she came back and
she's like it's okay Mama you just have
to do what you feel and I like literally
wanted to cry it was like do what you
feel do what your heart tells you you
know and she was so I was it was the
sweetest thing ever yes working method
is real it's so real but I have my
priorities in Olympia is that and
Serena's priorities might be shifting to
another little one Serena revealed in
her essay she and husband Alexis are
trying to have a second child quote we
recently got some information from my
doctor that put my mind at ease and made
me feel that whenever we're ready we can
add to our family I definitely don't
want to be pregnant again as an athlete
I need to be two feet into tennis or two
feet out it's a sentiment she hinted to
E.T earlier this year I definitely want
to have more kids it's just like balance
is key you know and just trying to find
that balance and you know I don't know
it's always like okay are we ready are
we ready so and I know the clock is
ticking so I'm just like okay I need to
figure out when that's gonna be but
hopefully soon well now we'll see no
pressure right
[Music]